while US Secretary of State Anthony
blinkin has called for humanitarian Aid
to be delivered to gazra and for all
Israeli hostages to be released he was
speaking at the United Nations where the
Security Council is meeting to discuss
the ongoing conflict in the Middle East
the un's Secretary General Antonio guz
also addressed the
chamber it is important to also
recognize the attacks by amas did not
happen in a
vacuum the Palestinian people have been
subjected to 56 years of suffocating
occupation they have seen their land
steadily divor by settlements and
plagued by violence their economy
stiffled their people displaced and
their homes
demolished their hopes for a political
solution to their plight have been
Vanishing but the Grievances of the
Palestinian people cannot justify the
appalling attacks by amas and those
appalling attacks cannot justify the
collective punishment of the Palestinian
people
let's hear now from some of the foreign
ministers from Arab Nations who held a
press conference at the United
Nations so let's just step back let's
not let rage determine the future of
millions of people in our region let's
just all let's allow common sense and
reason to come back and let's all
together the whole world in this United
Nations come and say it is time we solve
this challenge this conflict once and
for all and the only way is peace that
will fulfill the rights of all and would
allow all of us
to start working together to create
better future for our people a ceasefire
is a humanitarian imperative we are
facing a desperate situation in Gazza
right now we are facing an impending
humanitarian catastrophe every hour we
speak more civilians in razza are dying
more people are getting injured the
situation is getting worse a ceas fire
is an absolute necessary necessity
immediately that will allow us to
address all all of the other
issues Let's cross to the UN now Kristen
salumi standing by for us there in New
York and Kristen so do you get any sense
from today's speeches that the Security
Council is any closer to taking
action well we know that the United
States is working on a resolution they
have been in recent days negotiating
furiously behind the scenes with other
members of the security Council a
resolution that would give access to
Gaza uh what it refers to as
humanitarian pauses uh in order for Aid
to get into the region a resolution that
strongly condemned Hamas and defended
Israel's right to defend itself uh under
international law but also called for uh
you know respect for Palestinian
civilians and and deplored the loss of
civilians on both sides essentially so
this has been in the works uh but we
heard during the meeting today uh from
Russia that they have some issues with
this Russia said that it is concerned
that by failing to call for a
ceasefire the resolution would give
cover to an Israeli ground Invasion uh
by not demanding an immediate ceasefire
so the question now is where do the
other council members stand on and
Russia by the way said that it would
submit its own draft resolution to be
voted on after the United States vote
the United States initially called for a
vote this morning and then withdrew that
call suggesting that maybe they wanted
more time to negotiate with people on
the council so where do the other people
stand if us drafts and if the US draft
is if the US will veto Russia and Russia
will veto the US where do the other
Council members stand and that's where
we got some sense in the council uh
France for example was uh calling for a
the need for humanitarian pauses that
could lead to a ceasefire a bit
ambiguous uh but China and many
non-permanent members of the council
were pretty clear in calling for an
immediate ceasefire uh notably the
United Arab Emirates the Arab member of
the council was very strong in calling
for an immediate ceasefire so there
seems to be some back and forth and
disagreement over the terms of a
resolution yet and uh no known uh vote
scheduled at this time uh Kristen many
things said by many people including of
course the Secretary General Antonio guz
what was it that he said that prompted
the Israeli foreign minister to cancel
his meeting with
Ceres
yeah well you heard a little bit of what
he said um just a few minutes ago the
after calling for um after calling for
the unconditional re after condemning
hamas's attack on Israel and calling for
the unconditional release of the people
being held by Hamas he went on to say
that the attack did not happen in a
vacuum and that Israel had has uh
subjected the Palestinian people to 56
years of suffocating occupation this
prompted the foreign minister to cancel
his meeting with the Secretary General
he and the UN ambassador from Israel
have called for the Secretary General to
step down from his position they were
very clear about this we asked uh for
the secretary General's response uh his
spokesperson said only that the
Secretary General would be meeting in
the coming hours with with the families
of those people who are in Hamas custody
and they would be brought to him by an
Israeli
representative all right Kristen thanks
for that update there from the UN that's
Kristen salumi in New York let's now
bring this all together with Maron
bashara alzer's senior political analyst
joining us now from London so Mar what
did you make of the comings and goings
at the UN
today well there are two things that
struck me Nick uh one is the the
secretary General's speech I thought for
a change he was balanced sober and uh
rather put everything in context uh
since the Secretary General gueras is
supposed to represent the sort of the
soul and the spirit of what is the
United Nation and and what is
international law I thought he he hit
all the right notes uh in terms of
speaking about uh the historical
Injustice to the Palestinians the meager
attempts at helping them today the
inability of the International Community
to act and as well as condemning uh the
killing of civilians both Israelis and
Palestinians while speaking about why
why the International Community cannot
just keep uh you know watching as
Palestinians uh die in their thousands I
thought I thought that was at last you
know the Secretary General speaks in the
spirit of what is what is international
law what is International Community but
has it shifted
terms might might be about to happen and
then come on to your second
Point yeah the second point is just
quickly
that it seems like it's we are in the
theater of the Absurd right everyone
talks about everything and everyone
talks past everyone and everyone
contradicts every other one and even
those who like the foreign ministers and
the Arab countries spoke they spoke more
like political analysts or or
journalists rather than
politicians who have uh you know who
have leverage and who are able to uh put
their weight and uh and uh you know put
make an ultimatum to the likes of the
United States and and other members of
the UN Security Council so all in all I
think what happened in the United
Nations today did not affect the
situation in Gaza people continue to die
in their hundreds a day in Gaza
regardless apparently of what happens at
the United Nations right interesting
lots of things happening today we've had
various comments from the White House
including saying that the US has taken
no position on the legality of gaza's re
of Israel's reoccupation of Gaza should
that happen what do you make of
that I tell you uh mean I actually
salute uh uh secretary blinkin for his
for his capacity for spin I mean I've
never seen a speech uh with so much spin
in it uh really speaking in wonderful
tone about human rights about you know
about about about carrots to the
Palestinians while basically you know
doubling down behind Israel's sticks
really in the end of the day thinking
like as if the Palestinians are donkeys
that could be treated with with carrots
and sticks give them some money commit
some more dollars but at the same time
you know dispatch few more American
bombs to kill more civilians in Gaza
speaking from uh really out of both
sides of his mouth in such double
standard it was it was it was you know I
don't know what's the it was frustrating
listening to the spin with such a
you know such a laidback tone such a
wonderful soft uh approach but in the
end of the day as I said uh they speak
but people die in
Gaza away from the American east coast
uh president macron of France has been
meeting with president abas in rala
how's that going to shape things how
important is
that I tell you this is another uh
another shock and awe to today listening
to the French President uh you know it's
as if uh
islamophobia has drove uh some of the
western leaders crazy uh we we're back
to the logic of the 2003 or post 2001
911 and France that suffers from a lot
of attacks on its uh you know civilians
by various terrorists and so on so forth
can't seem to distinguish between what's
happening in Palestine and ISO and and
and alqaeda so for him to speak about
the need to expand the coalition to
fight isil into fighting Hamas is just
pure craziness all right M so much to
chew on and we'll do that again a little
bit later for the time being thanks a
lot M Bashar there in
London so we were just speaking about
the statements that have been coming out
tonight of the United States earlier the
National Security Council spokesman uh
John Kirby said a ceasefire in Gaza
would only benefit Hamas let's bring in
our White House correspondent kimy halat
in Washington DC so kimbery tell us more
about what we heard from John Kirby and
the White House tonight and what it all
means yeah well what the spokesperson
was saying there is that despite the
worldwide protest and the pressure that
this white house and Israel is under uh
to enact a ceasefire that is exactly the
opposite of what the White House and
Israel is favoring right now instead
what they're saying is that they might
be considering humanitarian pauses uh
but this is in terms of a ceasefire
something that they believe would only
benefit Hamas and as for uh the aid that
might be allowed to go in in terms of a
humanitarian pause the US President Joe
Biden saying that he feels Aid as it
stands right now is not getting in fast
enough and John Kirby the spokesperson
saying as of today tu Tuesday no trucks
have been able to get into Gaza to bring
food water medicine so another day where
civilians once again are going without
those critical supplies that they need
now as we know Palestinians are going
without those critical supplies uh John
Kirby the spokesperson told us that uh
the opposite is happening on the Israeli
side in fact when it comes to
evacuations he said that uh Israelis and
Americans in fact are uh not even taking
advantage of the charter flights in
terms of evacuations he said those are
continuing even as Palestinians are
trapped uh and in fact some of those
flights he said are half empty uh so it
really is a stark contrast what we also
know is that uh as we are reporting that
the Palestinians in Gaza are uh in dire
situations and uh without the very
Basics sometimes to sustain life uh the
White House is making no apologies for
that situation saying that uh there is
efforts underway to mitigate what they
call collateral damage but the bottom
line is John Kirby saying This Is War uh
so it was some pretty Frank talk quite
uh frankly Nick um but the bottom line
is is that this White House is saying
that the responsibility for all of this
is not Israel it is Hamas and they are
saying that Hamas is to blame not only
for what is happening now but this
originated in the eyes of the White
House on October 7th with that attack
yep all right kimy thanks for that kimy
halat there Washington DC at the White
House thank
you